l' enquête sur les attentats de new york
et washington la semaine dernière
elle se poursuit cette enquête aux états
unis et a connu des développements dans
le monde entier en europe après londres
berlin
c'est à paris ce matin que les policiers
de la dst ont opéré un coup de filet
dans les milieux islamistes sept
interpellations ont eu lieu
audrey goutard et mon chat pelard
bernard ap joseph baltique l'image
rappelle lé vaste coup de filet
antiterroriste des années 90 à une
différence près tous les individus
arrêtés sont considérés comme de gros
poissons
cette nuit la dst le contre-espionnage
français a visé une dizaine d'objectifs
en région parisienne
j'ai entendu du bruit à une heure du
matin la police est monté à frapper ses
nouveaux voisins en dessous parfois j'ai
entendu qu'un reporter vers 2h30 du
matin
je veux terminer mon voisin mon tueur
sept personnes ont été arrêtées selon
les policiers la plupart sont des
proches des réseaux ben laden dans les
appartements les enquêteurs auraient
trouvé des documents des plans et des
repérages de plusieurs villes de france
ils ont aussi saisi des armes
tout commence à dubaï en août dernier
les services secrets américains arrêtent
un islamiste franco algérien interrogé
l'homme dit connaître deux réseaux prêt
à frapper en europe en belgique
les policiers arrêtent un groupe qui
s'apprêtait à commettre un attentat
contre l'ambassade des états unis en
france en région parisienne un deuxième
réseau se préparait aussi c'est celui
qui a été démantelé cette nuit les
policiers les surveillaient depuis le
mois d'août il aurait bien voulu
attendre encore un peu mais les fuites
dans les médias les ont obligés à agir
tout de suite